like testing and learning distribution
other local information constraints
thank you thank you for inviting me and
so yeah I'm gonna talk about basically
testing and learning discrete decisions
and there are some local information
constraints this is based on a sequence
of works with China sure I could be
Freytag and Iman to TIG I'm gonna
mentions with mention which ones so I'm
going to start with a lie something
happened yesterday but I'm gonna pretend
it's today I don't know who have you
followed that but basically we sent
something to Mars which was pretty
impressive that something was
essentially a glorified thermometer
which doesn't make it less impressive by
the way I didn't draw that I that's from
the oatmeal so the question is why
[Music]
so yeah we sent I mean I didn't but NASA
sent something to Mars which is gonna
measure the temperature of mass and send
us back the results and from that
scientists would be able to infer
supposedly a lot of interesting things
so why am I telling you that
besides the shear interest of the fact
well we certainly sent something there
and we expect data back now there is one
thing in particular interesting about
this sitting it's it's pretty far and
it's pretty hard to get data back we've
got a lot of very stringent
communication constraints on things
coming back for obvious reasons we've
got a lot of noise we all serve the fact
that well you have energy battery
constraints you can't admit to stronger
signal you also have a limited window of
communication for example when there is
a giant celestial body in front of your
target it's pretty useless to send
something you've got to wait until it's
gone I pull the Sun I guess and well you
can't have too big of a transmitter
sighs we don't get to send a giant thing
there so you've got to miniaturize and
be pretty specific and say v about what
you send so this is a actually a good
example of also you've got the cost cost
of deployment I don't know the numbers
but we can't afford to do that every
time
beside the sheer fact that it takes a
lot like several months to get there so
we would like to have good protocols for
that kind of tasks all we do we minimize
the costs of sending that also a risk of
failure etcetera
accounting for such constraints that we
have to take into account how many
sensors can we put on that thing and how
many of those things are we able to send
or do we send information or do we
conscious eyes it already or do we send
it which kind of protocols is the most
reliable etc so all that is basically
following another general overarching
goal of or to make machine learning work
and there some constraints with we've
limited resources and of course I'm not
gonna answer that but I'm gonna try and
tackle the more specific question how do
we perform statistical inference and
there's some local information
constraints so the particles say oh by
the way if you've got questions don't
hesitate to interrupt me so the setting
I'm going to consider is called the SNP
the simultaneous communication protocol
model message passing it's also known as
the referee model and what we've got is
some prespecified inference tasks that
we want to solve over discreet
dissipations that are on a known domain
of size k also there's gonna be colors
just to keep track of the parameters i
don't leave that ELPS but kind of like
them we also have of course that unknown
distribution p underlying the question
we don't know what it is we just know
it's over that domain and well we've got
that referee somewhere that wants to
solve the task on that unknown
submission now how do we access that
distribution well we've got a bunch of
parties players let's call that N and
each of them as I said ask constraints
these constraints are going to be
modeled by a family of channels that I'm
gonna call curly w and each player the
protocol defines all they pick some
particular channel so a channel is just
a randomize function that takes an input
and output something the message
yeah W if I give you input X W of X is
gonna be the variable I Mac Dugan I'm
actually gonna use W Y conditioned on X
for the probability to output message Y
when you give it X it doesn't need to be
the same for all the players it just
needs that specified by the protocol and
each of these n players independently
gets one sample from the distribution
performs one measurement and then sends
the message to the referee and receiving
these n messages in a one shot fashion
and the name simultaneous there are
various to solve the task so now the
main question is based on all the
parameters we've got so blue K green W
and all the parameters of the task all
many some how many players do we need to
perform the task what's the minimum
number n that works a bit more
graphically this is essentially what
happens so here n is equal to 5 because
I can't draw more but so we've got these
five parties each of them picked a
channel so W want to W 5 and for example
the second one got input drawn from the
dissipation 271 that goes through the
randomized channel and sends 18 to the
referee etc and the referee reads the v
topo2 18:11 321 perform some computation
in a centralized fashion and says okay
that was a testing task says I accept
that the dispersion satisfies the
hypotenuse
so some remarks about that first of all
as I said W undercuts the local
constraints so in part here if you've
got the identity in there well there is
no constraint you go back to what I'm
gonna call the centralized case which is
the refrig it's all the samples now I
also like I've got that curly P for the
task what is an inference test it could
be done CG estimation it could be
parameter estimation functional
estimation like you want to estimate the
entropy of that distribution or it could
be I potus's testing or dispersion
testing property testing I'm gonna focus
mostly on dusty estimation learning and
property testing but you should keep all
those in in mind I am looking fuse who
is the channel like one dimension of k
dimensional distribution is that the
channel is just some functions that go
to channel so the channel is just a
function from 1 to K which is this
domain to some set of messages so 0 1 2
the number of bits you send and when you
when you get your sample from the
distribution say you get that number
which in 1 and K the channel just is a
randomized function that's gonna tell
you which message to output this house
we can give an example
I mean identity for example would be I
map 1 to K - 1 to K it's deterministic
if I if I use the example 17 I'm sending
17 it could be also like in 0 1 saying
like is it even or odd or it could be a
completely useless channel that just
outputs a random bit that's the kind of
that these are possibilities
the protocol specifies which channel it
each player no it's it's in the assimil
tenuous message passing things so it's a
one-shot thing you get each person gets
independently one sample they pass it
through their respective channels and
they send the messages and then the
referees that and just so you were
saying that you wanted to remove some
property of the distribution so then you
say I think it is trivial getting a
sample each player
you've got n players each of them gets a
sample so if they can just send their
sample the referee gets n samples from
the disobey so then for example if you
want to estimate the entropy of the
distribution
we just need n to be K of a lot k so all
I'm gonna talk about only deals with one
sample per person the techniques in
portrayal of the robots I'm gonna like
talk about completely break for more
there's been some work on it on
different models where for example for
example each person could get more
samples and the communication constraint
is maybe different etc so Elyas as the
work on such a model for learning needs
2007 gene I think but yeah yeah I'm
gonna focus on the case one sample per
person
the referee knows the protocol basically
doesn't the only thing the refer it
doesn't know is essentially well the
samples so the fail knows which protocol
the players are going to use knows the
number of players and of course knows
the task he or she is trying to solve
one popular thing I'm going to focus on
is you also have different available
resources so for example it might be the
case that all the players must be
deterministic
I'm not going to focus too much on that
it could be the case that can they can
use their own private randomness or it
could be the case that actually they
also can share some randomness think of
for example you get like the referee
gets to broadcast a random check run on
string at first it's easier to ear them
to send so each party can hear the
random string or it's specified by the
protocol and they share some randomness
so that would be public current
protocols and private currencies when
they actually can only use their own
private randomness as is the case in
communication complexity okay so I
mentioned a few tasks before I'm gonna
focus on two very specific ideas a
fundamental ones the first one I'm gonna
call dissipation learning and the goal
is given the messages received by the
referee atrophy as what put some
estimator p-hat of the unknown
distribution and with I probability I'm
gonna fix it to be a constraint it's not
with a constant probability that the app
needs to be closed in some parameter of
the task epsilon to the true
distribution and that's gonna be in
total violation / statistical or
equivalently l1 distance so that's the
first one the second one is a testing
task and that's that goodness of fit
without loss of generality uniformity so
the referee just needs to decide whether
that unknown distribution P is the
uniform distribution on the domain or is
far Epsilon far in again l1 distance
from uniform so it's a composite I posit
equity this testing question and again
you need to be correct with icons on
probability and when I say these are
fundamental so it's known that if you
can do uniformity testing you can do
goodness of fit or it's also called
identity testing against any
distribution you might know so that's
why it's efficient to focus
that so before I talk about what can and
cannot you do with information
constraints what is known if you don't
have those so it's for club I know that
if you want to learn a carrier
distribution to this to do l1 distance
epsilon without any constraint just you
need information theoretically
and it's sufficient to have K over
epsilon square samples it's also known
it's a little bit less fall Club the
actual type dependence in these
parameters dates from 2008 but if you
want to test for the distribution is
uniform or epsilon far from it you need
square root K over epsilon square
samples
that's the second one the dependence on
epsilon is due to penance
so know that that's the baseline and
what happens when you throw in actual
information constraints in that so
another question that I'm gonna focus on
is then do those public on a mess help
if they actually can share some public
random string the players beforehand
so of course we're not the first ones to
consider this kind of questions there is
a huge body of work with different kinds
of constraints the main - I'm going to
talk about our communication constraint
each player can only send at most L bits
or locally like local differential
privacy I'm going to get back to that
but essentially you've got over the past
years and decades a lot of work in
either similar models we've seen our
slightly different focuses or in
different areas and models so the plan
for the talk first I'm going to talk
about what I'm gonna call the
communication start sitting which is
when each player can only send L bits
the second I'm going to talk about
another kind of constraint which is each
pair wants to preserve their own privacy
formal sense and after that I'm gonna go
to a general lower bound framework that
encompasses the first two settings and
then there's gonna be your hidden
section which is just the conclusion so
if there is no constraint like there is
no public anonymous anywhere right the
referee direct directly as the samples
so yeah it doesn't help the referee just
observes the samples to begin with see
for simple hypothesis testing it was
shown that public randomness doesn't
help
so the first one is the communicate
communication starts sitting it's a work
with Jaidev and non true and I'm gonna
start with another story I don't know
what about who of you is familiar with
boaty mcboatface
I fear not I'm not gonna go through that
but you should definitely google it it's
worth it but let's say you're a little
bit concerned about let's say the
temperature of the of the world and you
want to send a fleet of observation
sheep she's sorry to measure the
temperature of the southern ocean to
check whether it actually matches the
temperature on record so there's a small
issue of course all these ships will
send back their measurements and the
southern ocean is a little bit not nice
in the sense of you've got storms
you've got arch collisions and you don't
have a Starbucks nearby to connect to
the free Wi-Fi so you actually have true
communication constraints there
you can't send that many bits reliably
so what is the best protocol in terms of
like ship efficient because these things
are expensive to build to Mannin to send
in order to test reliably whether the
dispersion of temperatures matches the
one on record so that's actually a case
of goodness-of-fit yeah another slice of
notation what how does that fit in the
previous thing well my family of
channels is going to be all the
randomized functions that map the domain
1 to k 2 l bits I can only son send L
bits and I'm gonna focus on the case
where L is strictly less than log K
because otherwise well there isn't
you have the identity in there and so
with a picture that's what it is each of
the boats will will send their output to
a central referee and first I would like
to claim there is one party approach
that if possible would allow you would
give an upper bound for all of that in
particular if there was a way given some
number of ships last parties to generate
one sample truly distributed according
to the unknown dissipation at the
referee then you could do anything you
can do in the central
model with some over it if it takes t
ships to generate one truly like one
sample truly this which it according to
P then like to solve something that
requires one thousand some polls you
just send one thousand T ships and you
retrieve all that the referee and then
you have one thousand samples so it
would be nice to know if it's actually
possible can the referee do that with
some number of players and the first
answer we gave is no you can't which but
essentially even if L if you can send
log K minus one bits
you can't simulate with any finite
number of players a sample truly
disability that according to P and the
proof is not that complicated it's some
suitable version of the pigeonhole
principle essentially we also give
another result that some trace says that
yes we can do that if we relax the
mentally a little bit so instead of
saying I want to generate given one
given T players one sample I can
generate one sample if I've got on
expectation some number of players so
more like Las Vegas I guess algorithm so
K over 2 to the L players are sufficient
to Jenner in expectation to generate one
sample and so before I discuss the
implications some flavor all that goes
for the case where L is equal to one I
take two K players and i pair them so
player one and two are gonna be focusing
on element one of the domain layer 3 and
4 and 11 - it's a try and player 2 I
minus one and two I are focusing on
element I and they're the bit they are
going to send is just one if the sample
is equal to I 0 otherwise
and then the referee receives these two
key messages and just outputs I if two
things happen first of all the player
two I minus 1 is the only odd-numbered
player
that is say is sending one and on top of
that player - I send zero so that sounds
a little bit strange if you look at it
it's not out to show that well either
they refer it doesn't output anything
because nobody are like none of these
conditions is satisfied for any eye or
if they're afraid outputs something is
going to be distributed with the right
probability also the probability to not
output anything can be upper bounded by
some quantity that only depends on the
two norm of the distribution and then we
want to bound that away from one in
order to be able to say on expectation
if you repeat that enough times it works
and when I say when you repeat your to
repeat it in parallel because you only
have one round and there are some tricks
that you can use to bond that away from
one and then you get so we can simulate
maybe for some applications it would but
if you want to give truly a universal
upper bound that's not gonna be good
right because depending on the task
maybe it's gonna be actually very
sensitive to our close you are to the
distribution so then you would have to
go to a much more fine-grained saying
like if I want approximation like
something that is distributed close
enough
etc
well yeah anything that's not Lipschitz
with regard to total relation distance
is gonna be bad and they are them might
not be always the most interesting
properties that they exist so when you
say that you have one brownie doing
everything in parallel what does it mean
to have an expected number of parents
that per se it just if I had at my
disposition and infinite infinite number
of players I would only need on
expectation to look at that many of them
infinite sequence of players they're all
already like they all send me a message
but I only actually look at some of them
I'm not gonna use that by itself I'm
gonna use it as a building block so yeah
just to bounce on that how do we use
that as a building block here's the
corollary if I know how to perform some
task with sample complexity s in the
centralized model then now I can do that
with s times K over 2 to the L players
and then with probability of failure
that's gonna be a constant and the idea
is just basically Markov inequality
I only look at that many players and if
I don't get enough samples then I say
about and a Scolari's of the calories
well learning a distribution with scale
verbs you n square well now it's K
square over 2 to the L epsilon square
and well if I want to test it was square
root K epsilon square now it's scheduled
to three hours over two to the epsilon
square and these since I wrote private
cone it's actually deterministic because
the way to simulate is deterministic so
that's good we've got some upper bound
on these two tasks now of course also
the simulation thing I mentioned is also
optimal but like the proof is a little
bit contrived
you can prove that this is optimal and
so if you could simulate in a better
fashion you would break the robot okay
so we've got this now the question is is
it really all you can do is there
anything better than that that you can
do and I mean given the whole thing
about private and public coin it should
be kind of obvious that the answer is no
there is something better so know if you
allow the players to share some
randomness of course independent of the
input space yes
then you can do better for the testing
case and in particular I claim there is
a public coin protocol for testing
uniformity of a domain size scale with l
bits for per player so again think of L
as I don't know constant or like
slow-going function of K where now you
only pay would you only need K over 2 to
the L over 2 epsilon square players so
you save essentially a square root K
over 2 to the L square root 2 K over 2
to the N and I'm gonna give the idea of
the proof oops
so it's we're gonna rely on that lemma
that I'm gonna call minimally
contracting ashing because it's a kind
of hashing and the minimally contracting
will hopefully make sense at the end of
the talk but essentially what happens is
the claim is just if you pass on
uniformly at random the domain K into
side into parts of equal size L in Elvis
array of size K over L and you look at
what the original distribution gives as
an induced dispersion of these L points
then the distance is going to be
preserved with constant probability up
to some contraction factor that's going
to be square root Big L over K so also
if you were uniform needless to say
you're still uniform because every part
has the same size so that preserves
uniformity and also that the distance of
uniformity is shrunk but not by too much
by that factor and the truth is not too
complicated
essentially it's well you want to deal
with this but you have dependencies
because
you take a uniformly random balanced
partition but if you use a standard anti
concentration inequality plus bonding
the second and fourth moment you will
actually get this statement and also all
the parameters up to constants are tight
if you just take the dissipation that's
very close to uniform at 1 plus minus
epsilon times uniform on each point this
is essentially what you will get because
on any part things will cancel out
pretty much standard deviation so that's
the limit we're gonna use twice in that
talk if I've got time how do we apply it
well Big L is gonna be 2 to the little L
the players have public coins they share
underneath so they can definitely pick a
uniformly random partition all together
the same with constant probability
they're going to be lucky it's one that
preserves the distance up to that factor
and now they just can send the samples
on that induce distribution over 2 to
the L points to the referee because
they've got Al bits and the referee will
just test uniformity with these new
parameters so the new domain size is Big
L and new distance parameter is epsilon
prime which is epsilon times that
contraction factor and things actually
work out if you use the standard like
the centralized algorithm that's good no
that was only with constant probability
what do you do well you take a constant
many times more players and you've got
bunches of people doing that and since
uniformity is always uniform you can
actually complete by that - probably 2/3
and the interpretation is you use /
become an S to essentially randomly map
the domain to a smaller domain but one
that provides the best trade-off between
the information constraints you have the
domain reduction and also distance
shrinkage in Chi square distance it was
kind of hidden because I didn't phrase
the lemma like that but it's actually
what's preserved is the l2 distance and
actually since I'm dealing with
uniformity testing l2 distance and Chi
square distance are equivalent another
hood that's essentially what's happening
here and well it's a simple algorithm as
we will see that contraction thing
against it's very general the only
drawback is you use a lot of bits to
pick up a lot of common randomness to
pick up that partition but since the
analysis only looks at second and fourth
moment actually all you need in there is
going to be for wise independence so you
can use something a little bit more
efficient and I will see that
contraction again if that line is a bit
mysterious just wait a little bit but
this is what we get I rewrote it in a
way which is this is the centralized
complexity times the blow-up factor so
for private coin learning private public
doesn't help for testing you actually
get a square root in the contraction
factor these are all upper bounds
now I'm gonna go to the second part of
the talk which is local differential
pricing that's the third part I don't
want to spoil it surprise so I'm gonna
talk about local control policy for
those of you that are familiar with
differential privacy essentially DP asks
that the algorithm that you run the
output of the referee doesn't give too
much information in a distributional
sense about any particular input local
differential privacy is a strengthening
of that and it's really you don't even
want to leak that information to the
centralized referee so Batman doesn't
want the algorithm to know is actually
Bruce Wayne so if I pull that for you so
that's it's actually what local
differential privacy is you know sitting
well we've got set up channels which are
that's kind of a tautology but that are
the channels that map to an arbitrary
message domain and these channels must
preserve row differential privacy up for
those who are keen on the super busy
sorry I renamed epsilon to Rho so
already taken and that actually requires
that on any two different inputs points
received by a by any user they for the
permit gender of any message and these
two different inputs is within a factor
essentially one plus Rho e to the roll
so that's the family of channels we're
dealing with and again they're
randomized and now the difference one
striking difference is they can send
arbitrary length of a message if they
want but they do have to not reveal too
much about the input in that's in that
so in that work with driving on Shue and
Cody we first give private coin upper
bounds so for those who know what
rapport is it's mechanism by Google and
another one is Adam our response that's
a bit more recent and we give two
protocols that essentially take the
output of these mechanisms and apply
some post-processing to do the testing
learning was already known by previous
work and we also give a public coin
upper bound which we call wrap down
which essentially uses the previous
contraction theorem with L is equal to
one so two differently all the players
will use their public randomness to just
divide the domain into so that when they
just project their sample their
independent sample on that they get one
bit each to send and if there is one
thing we know to do privately is to send
one bit essentially you can use pretty
much any optimal mechanism for that it's
Yuri randomized it's from a nice
response and well that gives the
following interpretation which looks
very similar to previous slide you use
public randomness to randomly map the
domain into a smaller domain which gives
the best trade-off between your
constraints and the distance engage of
the
and this is also something that looks a
little bit familiar so again this is
what you paid before in the centralized
sitting and this is the extra factor
again for learning public private Ronon
s doesn't help I've listened these upper
bounds but for testing you again get a
square root prediction this time it only
affects the K but you get a square root
reduction in private and public so all
I've given so far was upper bounds which
brings us to the third part lower bounds
so this is the latest work I'm gonna
talk about it it's with Jaidev and Iman
show and hopefully after that why I call
that the minimally contracting ashing
will make sense so this is essentially
what the outcome is every other Mon I've
given so far is optimal to constant
factors and as a corollary which should
not surprise any teacher I guess sharing
helps a lot for testing but not really
for learning any particular would get a
separation between testing uniformity in
the public and private coin case so
there's no question I'm gonna go but how
to prove these things this is all for
just one round yeah all that is so we
think all these results if you're
willing to blow up the notation will
extend to some trip for the curl where
the first player sends that and the
second player sees the outcome of the
first player plus its own it's the try
to draw but not in the food a lefty at
adaptive setting with several wrong so
do we prove such a lower bound well to
prove a lower bound against testing
there is that construction that was due
to pan in ski to prove the centralized
bound which is essentially what is the
other's case to prove it to test
uniformity it's something that looks
very close to uniform so here's the
formal definition but with a picture
it's just assume without loss of
generality that your K elements K is
even you pair them in buckets of size
two and then for each of the K over two
different buckets you it's either going
to be 1 plus epsilon over K 1 minus
epsilon over K or
all the other one so you've got carrot
to coin flips independence and you just
have that small perturbation so that
gives a family of two to the K over two
different disability are all epsilon far
from uniform and we want to say that
it's our to distinguish samples from
uniform the uniform dissolution in
samples that are drawn for one of these
picked at random at least that's what
you want to do in the centralized case
now we've got that extra thing that you
don't want to look at the output like
the samples you want to look at the
samples after going through the channels
which is the main difference so you've
got an extra layer of abstraction there
and to do that we would like to publish
upper bound the distance the total
ration distance between what is the
distribution of these n messages when
the input is actually the uniform
disabil
the dissipation of these and messages
when the input is not the average of the
dispersion of these and messages and
they're the other instance but the
distribution of these n messages under
the average are distance which is the
main thing that allows you to prove
there the tight bond in the sunrise
setting differently one main issue is if
you want to do that the dissipation of
the N messages under the average ad
instance is no longer probe distribution
you don't have that nice product
structures of you've got n different
things and so it's a n product
distribution so it becomes odd to
actually bound this thing directly but
if you want to do so the right proxy to
use is the Chi square distance so again
you want to bound the TB distance
between the transcripts in the two cases
yes and no case so you can start by
saying that the N one distance square is
upper bounded by the Chi square distance
and I want to show that this is much
less than one because that means it's
impossible to distinguish given these n
samples these end messages and other
annotation is why u n is the dissipation
of the n messages when the input
distribution is the uniform dispersion
you
and PZ is the odd instance when Z is the
vector of K over two bits that defines
that instance
so if you go through that you're going
to end up for every channel w you will
associate a positive semi-definite
matrix H of W that's of dimensions K
over 2 times K over 2 with whether I
want I to entry's defined that way and
after a little bit of work what you're
going to end up doing is characterizing
the contraction the distance contraction
after passing that through the channels
in terms of 2 norms of these metrics
namely the Frobenius and the trace norm
of these metrics and that's reminiscent
of the framework of SQ lower bounds via
high school construction contractions
especially given the fact i've been
talking about local differential policy
and there is a relation no relation
between what you can learn in the SQ
model and what you can learn in the
different trip locally differentially
private model however here we actually
get a different characterization in
terms of different norms that are
tighter namely the trace and the problem
is numb versus the spectral norms so if
you're familiar with these works
essentially if you try to apply that
directly you will get much weaker bonds
that work than what we get and also what
I said before yeah yeah it's one one
wrong yeah
so be what I said just does work and
give the right bone for public current
protocols but it would give the same
bond from private current protocols
because I just defined one bad instance
of dissipation and we want to hire lower
bound which this is not going to gain
our give sorry we need a better
perturbation than the Panisse keep your
table ation to get optimal and so we can
generalize the previous thing where like
the perturbation we want to come up with
some perturbation over minus 1 1 over K
over 2 so does that the bad instance is
going to be defined that way and
essentially if you take Z to just be a
sequence of independent plus 1 minus 1
uniform you will get back the previous
construction but now we get to pick that
construction it's actually before we had
one perturbation that worked again it's
all possible public-owned for the cost
because the public own protocol is a
convex combination of protocols now we
want to actually given some particular
private current protocol we want to
design some perturbation that's going to
defeat it pull it and so we're going to
try and choose that perturbation Z to do
that by looking at what the collection
of n channel those n channels do and try
to hide the distance in the directions
which give the least information
possible to the referee according to
that so essentially you can look at the
eigenvalues of that matrix HW I've
talked about and try to hide it I'd the
perturbation in like the eigen value
eigen vectors direction that correspond
to the smallest eigen values it's a it's
not really what we are doing here and
that's more 11 view it's we get max min
type of bound instead of a min Max and
if you didn't really care or miss that
it's actually the upshot is we give
lower bounds but learning testing with
public or private coins and all of that
depends on these two quantities which
are the Frobenius norm of the
corresponding metric
the maximum of all allowed channels and
trace known of this and
pounding these things actually gives the
ro bones I claimed I know you're gonna
have to trust me on that but bonding
these two things for the locally private
setting and also for the communication
start settings takes in each case five
lines and which that gives is this
magnificent table if you don't want to
kill your eyes also I'm going to put my
slides on line but these are exactly the
same thing as the upper bones I gave
before except that now there are lower
bones and this is the general the
general statement which is for general
family of channels this is what we get
now the last part the conclusion so what
exactly happened there well we looked at
our pairwise distances between
distributions contract when you pass
them through channels through the
channels belonging to that green w and
well pairwise distance will contract and
contract in which measure like the right
one we argue is chi-square divergence
but what we do is we give a quantitative
characterization of that construction
and also matching protocols that achieve
it and that actually leads to a very
general view if you want to find optimal
algorithms against some kind of
information constraint well you should
look at this thing and design schemes
that minimize that contraction
so as a conclusion we give a general
framework for infants programs with
local constraints of a discrete
dissipations which capture our special
cases the communication start and the
locally private regimes and give optimal
bounds for those this is the first work
we were aware of on disability testing
except for that silly I still confronts
it but work from 93 that considers and
we give optimal protocols for the public
coin and private coin uniformity testing
in all the settings we considered of
course there are many directions and
questions to explore one of them well
what if each person gets two samples for
example or like many I can say if each
person gets infinitely many samples it
becomes pretty easy you just have one
bit to sent but what happens in between
all our bond framework doesn't apply as
it is and the upper bonds actually show
that it's not mystery why another
interesting direction would be what
happens in the continuous case and in
particular for the general parametric
setting so we've got some preliminary
results when you want to test whether
the mean of a Gaussian is zero or big
it's a big no under these kind of
constraints and that's pretty much all
[Applause]
so this is also not by me this is by
somebody named Emily
[Applause]